sometimes it can feel like men and women
in relationships want entirely different
things like they're struggling to
communicate and connect on the same
level about the same set of priorities
Jordan will now explain exactly why that
is but outside of the context of a
relationship all of us struggle in our
lives for a variety of different reasons
and what Jordan's particularly good at
is telling anybody who's right now
listening to this that is struggling in
some way or finds themselves in a
situation where they're struggling to
get out and climb out of that situation
step by step how to do that how to turn
that situation into the greatest success
of your life and that's why I loved this
conversation and why I think you're
going to love it too and before this
episode starts I've got a 10-second
favor to ask you that are listening to
this right now 62% roughly of people
that listen to this podcast haven't yet
hit the Subscribe button if you could do
me any favor at all it would be just to
hit that subscribe button helps this
channel immensely and if you do that for
me I promise with my team to do
everything we can to make this show
better and better and better for you do
we have a deal enjoy the
[Music]
episode
Jordan we had a conversation before and
it reached tens of millions of people
and as I went through the feedback and
the comments of that conversation I
found one that really stood out to
me someone said I had just days of will
left in my
body I felt like a
failure I hadn't reached the potential I
knew I had in me despite effort I
couldn't become the person I was so
desperate to
become and then I found
Jordan and his unfiltered words pulled
me from my darkest moment just in time
now my life is in my hands once again
and I've built a career and a life I'm
proud of so thank you Jordan we may
never meet but you've saved my life and
my children still have their father
because of
you it is one hell of an
impact that you've had on just that
single person's life how do you receive
such incredible
feedback from a stranger you've never
met well when when you were reading that
you know I mean it it's obviously a very
positive thing to hear but my mind
immediately went to why that's the case
see I've been in the fortunate position
of being able to
synthesize and then communicate a
centuries worth of clinical research and
experience gathered by very many
extremely intelligent and careful people
and then on top of that whatever I've
managed to gather being reasonably
educated in the broader sphere of the
humanities and Sciences let's say and
the effect
that this individual is attributing to
me as a consequence of that right I've
been successful because I've been a
conduit of good ideas and I have the
ability to synthesize a lot of
information and to communicate that to
people in a way that's understandable
the the person who made that comment you
know they were struggling for one reason
or another and one of the things you do
with people who are struggling is you
make the simple even simpler because
then they can get a toe hold you know
like if if they're really barely able to
move I had one client you know he was H
he had a hard life man he was like 85
he'd fallen off a ladder and broken his
neck and they had permanently Fus it so
he was basically like this he could
hardly move he was so depressed he
literally couldn't get out of bed you
know it was awful and he was in chronic
pain because of his broken neck and so
you know the first thing I did with him
was get him to sit up for like 30
seconds that was it that's where he had
to start you know and after I I worked
with him when he was in the hospital
after two weeks he was walking down the
hall and able to sit up and read for you
know five or six minutes and he got out
of the hospital he went home and but he
had to
start with the simplest possible steps
and hey man you start this is the
definition of humility in some ways is
that you start progressing where you can
start I think about this a lot because
there's a lot of people that are
objectively or subjectively down and out
in their lives that's how they feel and
it's often too intimidating to present
them with the idea of climbing Mount
Everest today a proverbial M Everest
like just pick yourself up and go to the
gym and work out be healthy right and
that yeah no that's not going to happen
it's like putting them at the foot of
Mount Everest but the small commitments
we keep to ourself are often really
undervalued because they seem so trivial
like you saying well that's the Casual
contempt that's another aspect of that
well one of the really difficult things
to learn when you're down and out is how
far you're down because it's humiliating
you know I was Ill recently and when I
started to recover I couldn't really I
couldn't really button my shirts I had
to learn to do that again I did I had
forgotten how to put my hands on
keyboard I didn't know where to put my
hands I had to learn to type again now I
hadn't lost all the knowledge and it
came back quite quickly but and the
reason I'm saying that is because one of
the impediments to people who've really
taken a blow in their life is that
things have fallen apart around them so
badly that where they have to start is
humiliating even to consider the rule
it's a pretty straightforward rule when
you want to get back on your feet and
the rule is you have to make the task
small
enough so that you'll do it no matter
how small that is you know and that can
and I I've worked with people I mean one
of the things I become well known for is
my advice to start by cleaning up your
room but I had plenty of clients who
couldn't they couldn't go home and clean
up their room they hadn't cleaned up
their room for like 20 years for all
sorts of reasons maybe because every
time they did try to do anything
positive in their family no matter what
it was they were immediately punished
and
undermined and so if they even went home
and dared to start cleaning up the room
they'd face resistance within the family
that was just a manifestation of the
50,000 times they'd been discouraged in
the past but also a move that would
upset the insanity that characterized
the pattern of familial interaction
actions and so actually when if they
even made a move to clean up their room
what they were doing simultaneously was
confronting the dragon in the family
that had made every single person in
that household insane for like five
generations right so it looks simple
it's not bloody simple and so in a
situation like that you cut it down so
that maybe the first thing they do is
clean up like maybe they look inside one
drawer and see the mess that's there and
just look at it for a minute and think
about how they might reorganize it if
they were going to when people are very
down and out and they decide to make a
move forward in some ways they're facing
the whole panoply of problems that
confront them in in the guise of that
single problem right it's all lurking
behind it right it's like you know they
see the tip of a reptile's tail outside
a gigantic closet let's say and they
look and they think well that's just the
tip of a tail how what harm can it do me
but it's connected to the whole damn
Beast and the advantage to that is that
if you make that first step forward
you're actually advancing in the form of
in the face of all that opposition the
disadvantage is that the first task
seems so small that you literally have
to be on your knees to be humble enough
to lower yourself to take that first
step you know God is that all I can do
I'm so
useless you might even be more useless
than that because you might fail out it
I had lots of clients who would come
back you know we'd make a deal that they
would do something simple I remember one
client is such a comical story in a
terrible dark way you know he was an
overgrown infant and he was 30 he was
still living at home in his messy you
know High School room under the thumb of
his mother conveniently for him CU then
he never had to do anything and he had
managed to entice some girl into
sleeping with him and she got pregnant
now he's going to have a son and he had
enough sense to come to me and say you
know I'm kind of a wasil and I've mucked
up my life but maybe I'd like not to
destroy this kid so is there something I
could do to put myself together so you
know we talked that through we
negotiated which is what you do with a
client if you're sensible you know you
lay out the problem first okay what the
hell's wrong with you do you think you
have to listen and listen and listen
well the person unfolds everything that
might be wrong they put all their cards
on the table and then you sort through
through them and you think well some of
that even they'll figure this out
themselves some of that's not really the
central issue and so you imagine they
lay all the cards on the table and then
you kind of get rid of 90% of them it's
a symptom it's a symptom yeah yeah it's
it's it's it's it doesn't really bother
me now that I've talked about it that
doesn't seem key I think I'm really done
with that that isn't interesting to me
but they'll still have to lay it all out
and then you focus on the problem and
then the next thing you think is ask
them is something this is great General
problem solving strategy is okay if this
could be better as far as you're
concerned what would better look like
and then they have to lay their cards on
the table about that so you do the same
thing and now you have the diagnosis
that's the problem statement and now you
have a
hypothetical uh cure let's say and now
you need a strategy right and that would
be the steps in between the problem and
the final destination then you break
down the steps until you find a step
that they that the person will take have
to do that experimentally so the first
step for him was to vacuum the carpet in
his in his room and so this is literally
what he did he brought the vacuum it was
a standup vacuum he brought that into
his room but he only got it to the
threshold and then he left at 45° across
the door late leaning and he walked over
it for a whole week and so then he had
to come back and tell me you know and he
was embarrassed he said you know I got
the vacuum cleaner
just to the doorway and I left it there
and then instead of bringing it into my
bedroom I just you know I put an
obstacle in my own path and stepped over
it for a whole week it's a very
humiliating thing CU he knew that his
life was on the line and he knew that
his son's life was on the line and he
knew that he was one useless bastard for
not being able to bring that vacuum
cleaner into the room you know but the
proper interpretation of that in part is
well you got the bloody out of the
closet didn't
you you know so what we did was
renegotiate this is called technically
this is called collaborative empiricism
it's a behavioral approach for
clinicians and the the collaboration is
well as I said what's the problem
diagnosis what's the potential solution
the person has to be on board with all
this right I mean they have to be the
people who decide that's the problem you
can't enforce that on them they have to
discover it for themselves and the same
with the solution and the same with the
strategies it's like I don't know what's
right for you oh listen we can jointly
explore what might be the right vision
for you and then we can break that down
into a strategy but you you have to be
on board with the strategy you have to
feel that this is right for you it's
absolutely 100% crucial that it's
voluntary and then we'll say okay well
maybe this is a solution why don't you
go imp it come back next week after
having attempted this let's see how it
went you know and sometimes people come
back and say well you know that went
great and it started me and I did three
other things and you know what we seem
to be on the right track and sometimes
they come back and say nope that didn't
work at all like with the vacuum cleaner
and so then you have to think what you
do in that situation is make the task
smaller if you make the task small
enough I've never never seen
anyone not be able to progress if they
made the task small enough but you know
that can be pretty humiliating now the
upside is that once you've take that
first step youve look the beast in the
face and you'll start progressing not
linearly but exponentially in speed so
what's cool is that doesn't really
matter how small that first step is
because it'll start doubling and
anything that doubles grows unbelievably
quickly and so that's a very useful
thing to know too and that that's true
when you're learning anything new it's
like you you'll feel like an impostor
you'll feel like a fool cuz you are and
you'll think I'll never get there and
and it might the destination might look
very distant but if you take a
sufficiently small first step and get
the ball rolling you can be cruising
along at a pretty good rate generally
faster than you'll think what's going on
in one's psychology there is it building
evidence of your own capabilities and
capacity definitely what seems to happen
when you expose people to small but
challenging tasks it does two things it
makes them more skilled because now
they're actually dealing with the
problem and so they're acquiring the new
perceptions and the new behaviors that
are Mastery so they're actually
expanding their domain of conceptual
structures and actions that's that's
both conception and skill but at the
same time they're seeing themselves as
the actors that can change the direction
of their life for example when you do
exposure therapy with people who have
phobias agobia is probably the best
example so agobia is a condition where
people will become so terrified
generally of life that they they often
literally can't go outside their house
if they go outside their house their
anxiety levels climb to the point where
they have a panic attack which is like
the complete disinhibition of the fight
ORF flight system very overwhelming
experience people will go out and
they'll have a panic attack and then
they'll avoid where they had the panic
attack but then the probability of the
panic attack starts to spread so that
wherever they go they have a panic
attack and then they end up stuck at
home and it's quite a common condition
now the people who develop that are
generally women and that's because women
are more sensitive to anxiety than men
they're generally women who had an
over-dependent relationship with their
parents Maybe particularly their father
they're generally women who went from
their father to an to a boyfriend who
was either overbearing and
overprotective or who was enticed into
becoming that by the dependency of the
person of the sufferer and then so
imagine you're dependent young woman you
haven't learned to stand on your two
feet every time you had a problem you
were taught to seek Authority you
sheltered behind the protective walls
that someone else had established for
you you married someone like that now
he's he died or you're getting a divorce
or or so that wall is starting to come
down okay so all that existential Panic
starts to rise you start panicking when
you go out and you end up at home unable
to move also thinking you're the only
person in the world who's suffering that
way and so what you do is you find out
you you you do a problem analysis and
you find out their core fears and what
agrh bics are often afraid of elevators
and that's quite convenient because you
know there are elevators everywhere so
you can start having them confront Their
Fear of elevators so how do you do that
well if they're really
terrified you say well let's look why
don't you come sit by me and and uh
let's look at some pictures of some
elevators and you say look at the
elevator okay now imagine being 20 ft
from it how are you feeling they'll tell
you they're nervous you know they're
afraid they're going to get trapped in
the elevator they're afraid they'll have
a heart attack they'll they're afraid
that they'll be in there with other
people who are watching them panic and
have a heart attack and being humiliated
so the the two big categories of fears
for people are like painful death and
then public humiliation and if you have
a really good anxiety fantasy it's that
you're going to undergo a painful death
in a very humiliating way and so that's
what they imagine happening in the
elevator so it's not exactly that
they're afraid of the elevator right
they're afraid of death and humiliation
and the elevator a portal to the realm
of death and humiliation it's like I'm
afraid of an elevator okay how afraid
can you could you look at an elevator
from a 100 yards down the hall well like
if it isn't 100 yards than 125 yards
like you'll find some threshold that the
person can tolerate okay so now you're
at the threshold where their the
magnitude of their confidence is
precisely matched with the size of the
apparent Dragon right so and you they
feel that it's like there's a place
where their fear will they'll say that's
close enough it's like okay now you're
on the edge you're on the edge so now
we'll dance on the edge we'll move your
foot forward okay so let's move a foot
forward okay anything NE negative
happening well I'm feeling a little
nervous okay well let's just stand here
for a bit keep your eye on the elevator
don't don't hide because you can avoid
by just not looking and we do this all
the time we look away and the bigger the
dragon the more we're likely to look
away you know people don't people don't
like to look
at and you can understand why people
will avert their eyes from
atrocity right and they'll certainly
avert their eyes from the thought that
they could participate in atrocity and
you could think of that as the Heart of
Darkness it's it isn't because you could
look at the fact that you could take
Glee in the commission of atrocity
and and no one wants to look at that
well you start and you have to look at
that you have to look at that in the
final analysis but one step at a time
you know and and you can do that with
any problem literally any problem break
it down break it down break it down
public speaking anything going to the
gym anything anything a small dose you
know a small dose and it's it's it's so
fun to do this with people it's the same
thing you do when you're when you're
when you're encouraging your your young
child and that's a primary source of
gratification for human beings is
putting someone on the edge and
encouraging them and so you do that as a
clinician so I loved being a clinician
because you know people say well how can
you you know how how do you tolerate
listening to people's problems well
first of all they're not your problems
you have to understand that because if
they're your problems you're stealing
that person's problems from them you
know because you could come to me
especially people who are you know very
unsophisticated they can come and talk
to somebody like a a well experienced
clinician someone whose breadth of
knowledge exceeds theirs by a
substantial margin and that person can
just give them advice but then they go
act out that advice and then that's not
them they have to come to it themselves
this brings me to a point about trying
to help people in your life
because we all have people in our lives
that are struggling in some way and our
knee-jerk response is to get in there
and fix solve the this is a problem that
men often have when they're dealing with
women yeah they they leap to the problem
solution phase and they also do that in
some ways to avoid and this is what
annoys women because what the women want
and they don't even know this but this
is what the women want women are more
sensitive to threat than
men okay so they're looking for
Predators now predation detection is a
it's an intuition anxiety is an
intuition something's wrong okay what
well then you guess right so imagine the
threat system has sort of got something
in its sights but it it's a a sense that
something's not right but it's not fully
fleshed out the picture because serpents
are camouflaged right so the threat is
hidden well what the woman wants is to
lay out all the things that might be
wrong okay well the guy doesn't want
that cuz first of all you know maybe
your wife is upset about something in
relationship to your children and she
doesn't know what it is so now she has
to go through everything she thinks that
might be wrong well even for you to
listen that's going to be rough because
some of those things are going to be
about you and so you just have to shut
up and you have to let her put her cards
on the table understanding now she has
to do it in good faith right she can't
be using that opportunity to skewer you
and so these things are tricky to manage
but you want to listen to her lay all
the cards on the table now the advantage
to that is now you know where all the
hidden snakes are now if you do that
what you'll find out and so will she is
that most of the things that she's
worried about she's not actually worried
about she won't know that until she lays
them out on the table and can see them
and then both of you can triangulate to
the actual problem and then you can
negotiate a solution and off offer help
but if you jump right to help the reason
you can't do that is cu you you probably
have the problem wrong so so then back
to your question about helping one of
the most effective things you can do to
help people is to listen and there are
Technologies of listening and so the
first one is don't assume that either
you or the person who's talking knows
what the problem is it's so hard once
you have the problem specified IED
you've solved like 95% of the problem
it's re that diagnostic move is really
hard are we sure we're addressing the
most crucial issue you have to have your
sites focused right on the center point
of the Cross right like in a in a Gun
Site it's like are we aiming at the
right Target and then you can start
negotiating problem solution and so so
it's but you can develop the patience to
do that once you understand that that
initial active listening is in itself
the most helpful thing you can do just
listen and then how do you listen Okay
so if I'm listening to you there'll be
times when what you're saying doesn't
make sense and so then I'll just say
well you're saying this now but you said
this five minutes ago and if you listen
a lot you can learn to track
conversations across a very long span of
time and that's quite fun you said this
but then you said this and they don't
like they seem contradictory to me
you're not accusing the person you're
saying I see an inconsistency in the way
you're formulating the problem and
they'll sort of startle a little bit and
then try to rectify that they'll check
you out to see if you're insulting them
or trying to play a game of moral
superiority first but if it's just an
honest question then you're actually
helping them lay out a description of
the situation that's not internally
contradictory okay so and the great
podcasters do this you see this with
Rogan you know all Rogan does is ask
stupid questions M and the way he does
that is by Consulting with his own
ignorance in humility Rogan is listening
he's thinking I'm a stupid LK head and I
don't understand this what do you mean
and the what's that's brave because he's
exposing his own ignorance but it's it's
honest because he doesn't understand but
it also unites him with his audience
because especially with someone like
Rogan the probability at this time that
if Rogan doesn't understand the gist of
the conversation that 95% percent of his
audience doesn't understand is it's like
100% the importance of listening can't
possibly be overstated listen ask
questions until you understand and by
doing that you also help the other
person clarify the situation it is so
hard to do and I I think we have to just
pause at that step because it is as you
said you said like that's 95% of the
challenge it is so hard to do in
relationships in work I've sat literally
at this table with a colleague of mine
about a year ago and she was telling me
she worked in one of my companies she
was telling me that she's unhappy in her
role and I remember sitting here and she
gave me a bunch of reasons why and I
kept asking and asking questions and
after just 30 minutes of asking the
questions she had decided that in fact
everything she had just said was not the
issue and then it related back to a much
more fundamental issue of just meaning
in her work well see see okay well
that's very important that's very
important Yung called that a
circumambulation okay so now imagine the
threat system is going off right it's
saying something's wrong something's
wrong but it it's just it's an it's a
primordial predator predator detection
Instinct that's what's being triggered
it isn't High resol it isn't capable of
high resolution conceptual formulation
not to begin with something's wrong
something's wrong something's wrong okay
what maybe this maybe this maybe this
maybe this maybe this maybe okay now
what happens is the the Mayes Circle and
spiral right and as you lay them out you
spiral inward to the gist of the matter
but you have to see because you could
imagine while this woman is explaining
her problems to you she's talking about
things about the company and her
relationship with the company that might
be unsettling to you so you're sitting
there thinking well she's laying out her
problems maybe you're getting defensive
well that's not true the company's
better than that that's an unfair
accusation so you're feeling on the spot
plus you want to jump in with your you
know with your solution because you want
to show that you're bigger than the
problem that she's showing or maybe
you're secretly attracted to her and you
want to be a white knight I mean there
can be 50 things you're sitting there
thinking about what you're going to say
next because you want to play dominance
or maybe you think that's what you
should do because you're a boss and it's
like there's a lot of things that'll
interfere with listening But but so you
learn you say just shut up ask stupid
questions until really until the person
that you're listening to has specified
the problem now if you're very fortunate
both of you will convert on that and
it'll just become clear think oh you and
you pointed this out this is what that's
really all about now the person may be
discovering too that they were resistant
to that conclusion they you know because
the fundamental threat is more key to
their self-esteem that they to their
conception of themsel then allowed them
to be comfortable before they get to the
actual point which is where they're
going to be most vulnerable they're
going to throw out a bunch of screen
concerns just to see if you can be
trusted with something that will reveal
their vulnerability and they're even
doing that to themselves it's like dare
I tell the truth about this situation
because I've betrayed myself before so
maybe not you're so right they they test
you to the on the way to the truth to
see if how you'll respond yes and
they're testing themselves too and you
know and you can facilitate that see if
you facilitate that by calm listening
then you're modeling the fact that
whatever the hell they have as a problem
isn't so terrifying that you have to
avoid it and run away yeah right right
it's so interesting what what was
actually revealed because this person
that works in one of my marketing teams
in a different company where there's a
CEO said to me um it's the work she they
were doing that was causing them the the
iies and that's the reason they wanted
to leave Etc and I asked them the
question after about 30 minutes when was
the time you were most happy in the in
the business they revealed to me that
the time they were most happy was when
they were with me overseas at the very
beginning and what that really revealed
at at its Essence was there had been a
change in the proximity to me and the
real meaning of the work and they now
felt like they were doing trivial things
their happiest time was when they were
right next to me doing the most
important stuff the so the most
difficult problems they were solving the
most difficult problems when they were
most challenged and they were they were
so really the fix wasn't what they
thought it was the fix and then now they
actually text me I sent the message to
one of my team members last night saying
I just don't I want to keep keep their
identity so let's say they were with me
in Canada they text me when they were
most happy they text me last night
saying I feel like Canada Jenny again
right and all the adjustment that had to
be made was getting them back close to
bigger challenges so they wanted to be
closer to the front line as it turned
out when Freud first developed
Psychotherapy he developed this
technique of free
association okay so all free association
is and this is what for this is why
people put put Freud put people on the
couch and sat be behind them see if I'm
face to face with you and I'm laying out
the problem
space just what you're signaling to me
by your face might stop me from fully
revealing the truth because maybe you'll
raise an eyebrow or you there'll be a
micro um expression of disgust or
contempt or you'll look away or cuz I'm
going to be evaluating you to see how
you're reacting morally to my
Revelations so Freud just hid himself he
and and I I don't think that's strictly
necessary
but but but it's a very wise intuition
and you can imagine how it would be
helpful so now I think the counter to
that is you can signal to someone who
you're talking to like open reception of
the message they're receiving right it's
just that and kids love this right one
of the things kids are doing all the
time is testing you to see if you're
paying attention and they will modify
their behavior in any way imaginable to
get attention there's no it's because
there's no difference between attention
and love by the way like there's no
difference and so I don't think you have
to hide yourself from your client but
that's why Freud did it now what Freud
noticed and the psychoanalysts noticed
is that if you let people free
associate the the topics that they
picked would be linked to one another
that reminds me of this that reminds me
of this that reminds me of this now
obviously because people aren't just
emitting random noises there's a reason
the things they're revealing are linked
there's some implicit similarity that
they're striving toward now often
what'll happen if you listen to your
wife for example she's laying out a
bunch of problems and it'll spiral it'll
remind her of something this off this
happened with Freud if you got to the
gist of it it would remind people of
something that happened to them much
earlier in their life and often
something that was trauma atic that so A
trauma is a problem you encounter in
your life that's quite deep so that it
unsettles you that you do not resolve so
it's like it imagine that in your
bedroom there were holes that you could
fall through into you know into trouble
and so you want to make a map of where
all the holes are so that you can walk
through the landscape without falling
into the pit now it' be better if you
just fixed the holes but but at least
you have the landscape mapped out well a
trauma is a a trauma is a hole that
hasn't been filled in and so maybe you
if you had a trauma when you were four
you hit a wall and be you couldn't
resolve the trauma that's no different
than not maturing in relationship to
that problem so what you have at hand
there are the only the tools that you
develop by the time you were four now
then you might encounter a situation
where that's reminiscent of that so for
example
someone might sayi had a problem with my
boss I have a recurring problem with my
boss and so you listen to he says that
that reminds me exactly of what my
father did when I you know in this
situation when I was a kid and so the
reason the person is reacting to their
boss in a negative way is because
they're using the same conceptual
structure that they used to construe
their father when they were four you'll
see this in marriages all the time like
if you have a recurring problem with
your partner that's that that that you
really can't
understand now it might be
your fixation at some developmental
stage that's the problem like she's
interacting with you in a way that
elicits your 13-year-old self
consistently but she also might be
reacting to you in a way that elicits
her 13-year-old self and so then but if
you listen to her she'll get to that and
then she'll tell you the story and
then sometimes she'll be able to figure
out what to do about that herself or
sometimes you'll have to discuss it but
it almost always results in tears almost
always and I think the reason for that
is think that what happens is when
people break down in tears so children
cry quite often and they cry when they
encounter an impediment that they can't
surmount and I think what tears do is
dissolve you to the state of
neurological plasticity that
characterizes Early Childhood so that
you can learn now people don't like that
right that reversion it's humiliating
but you know you have to break that's
the crying the the crying is an
indication that the current conceptual s
structure is insufficient it has to die
then the tears come right and then now
you're prepared neurologically to learn
something new and that'll be whatever
comes out of the discussion and that'll
replace that old conceptual structure
that's outdated and immature with a new
somewhat fragile concept Cal structure
right and then the person will try that
out a couple of times like maybe you
this is something where you have it's
like something that's just come out of a
you have to be very careful when
you negotiate with your partner because
you know maybe they'll decide that
they'll try a new tactic that you you
have both agreed on but the first 30
times they Implement that new tactic
first of all they won't do it very well
because it's new and second if you
punish it it'll kill it right away yes
so you're describing my relationship
very accurately because I am someone who
in the mid so what's my my sort of
attachment style
I grew up in a household where my
parents were very were at each other a
lot it was fighting arguing so I learned
very early on that relationships are
like prison right so I wanted to
Commitment I ran from commitment my
whole life I met someone who had an
opposite attachment style where whenever
things get a little bit Rocky she wants
to like latch on in a sense like she
really wants to make sure that I she's
got my attention yeah for example I
could come home and say one word that
shows that I'm focused on my work and
then suddenly she's like fying for my
attention that makes me want to run and
that makes her want to chase right right
and so then she'll you know she'll get
triggered and then she'll kind of
retreat and be it's quote unquote like
the word sulking is often used um so we
came up with a system where I said to
her when you feel triggered by me not
giving you the attention you want and we
you end up spiraling can you just try
and tell me as soon as possible yeah
instead of like the 7h hour silence yeah
um so that was the mechanism we came up
with and then the first time she did
that I was as you said very conscious of
making sure I didn't react badly to it
or get triggered by it right so you're
you're describing the process I've been
through entirely yeah well this happens
this happens to everyone and those those
suks let's say that's that's a
non-verbal threat response right right
and and you want to replace that with a
more differentiated practical and more
immediate strategy you know and so you
know one of the things that I've seen
for example with my wife is that um the
periods of time where she gets upset
shrink and shrink and shrink and shrink
because she can get from the problem to
the verbalizable statement of the
problem and the solution way way faster
but that that takes just from continual
practice continual attention it's like
oh I'm upset okay well what am upset
about here's a bunch of things that I
might be upset about okay which of those
are focal like this is something you can
learn you know but you have to you have
to admit you're upset and you also have
to understand that you don't know why
because one of the things that'll happen
in a marriage with any close relation
with any relationship is like well if
you and I talk and we hit a pit it's I
would rather that it's your fault right
because then you have to take the
conceptual structure and you have to
allowed to die and you have to cry and
you have something to learn and it's you
and it's an indication that you're
insufficient it's way more convenient
for me if it's you plus I get to feel
moral Superior and like I have myself
under control and that I've you know
mastered the universe and also women
also in some ways want that from men
because they want the men to be
competent and so men will pretend to be
more competent than they are it's like
you want to find out what the problem is
because then you can solve it and and
one of the things you have to consider
is that you're you're the problem maybe
you're not but maybe you are now you
might say well why should you undergo
the cataclysmic Revelation that you're
the problem and the answer is because
you could stop being the problem like
that's the payoff because you might say
well why why attend to your wife why
fight and the answer is so you don't
have to fight again see and I know this
so I'm a very agreeable person I don't
like conflict like I'll do almost
anything to not to paper it over though
that's the thing to to fix it but the
reason that I'll engage in conflict is
because I know it isn't a theory I know
that conflict delayed is conflict
multiplied and so if I do have a problem
with someone I want to note it get it on
the table fight it through to the bloody
bottom fix it and move on and there's a
you know that's that's a lot of
emotional stress and complex
reconceptualization and retooling and
people would rather avoid that you know
because you know you come home from work
and your mind is on something whatever
the hell it is and then this like snake
pops up and you think do we really have
to deal with this now it's like well
maybe and if not now when and that's
something you can also negotiate you
know like I can give you an example of
that so
there was a time a very long time where
my daughter was insanely ill and
suffering brutally and deteriorating at
the same time and that's overwhelming by
definition because a problem you can't
solve is overwhelming and then so the
question arises well how do you deal
with a problem that's overwhelming that
you can't
solve without making it worse so one of
the things that Tammy and I did was we
made rules it's like we didn't talk
about Michaela after 8:00 at night it
was just off the table because we knew
well are are you going to are you going
to go to sleep are you going to need
some sleep tonight like if we're going
to battle this for like decades we
better not wear ourselves out okay how
not to well let's make some rules
they're like negotiating rules and you
you can do this this is good advice to
the degree you can give people advice
about a relationship here's something to
understand about your marriage okay you
are going to have to listen to your wife
90 minutes a week okay and you might as
well just
get that through your thick skull now
why if you listen to her enough you can
make peace and you can play so there's a
huge benefit if you don't listen to her
that will
accumulate and you'll listen to her in
divorce court like you will eventually
listen and at some point you'll pay for
the privilege of doing so right because
there'll be other people involved and
then the backlog will be so high that
you might never escape from it why don't
men like to listen
well often because the insufficiencies
are pointed at
them you know and and and sometimes
especially if the woman let's say and
this can go both ways let's be sure
about this but we'll we might as well re
revoke revert to the stereotypes and I
think it's fair because women are more
threat sensitive so they're more likely
to bring up problems now that's the
disadvantage is they bring up problems
that don't exist because that's a false
positive but the advantage is they bring
up problems before your sensitive enough
to see them and so this is very
important if you think about the role of
women is the woman is closer to the
infant than
you okay so you're you know doing
whatever the hell you're doing you're
concentrating on your career you know
you're not especially when the infant's
under a year old you're a step removed
now and good you can be dealing with the
external world but she's concentrating
on the little kids and one of the things
you want to hear from her is what the
hell's wrong with the kids before you're
wise enough to see it now the price you
pay for that is she might be shorting
out about things that don't exist so you
know and this is especially true if your
wife is high in neuroticism and it could
be true if the husband is too but as I
said that's the more stereotypical
situation so why listen to get to the
signal now will she get to the signal
yes although she might not be very good
at that and it might take a lot of
listening but if you listen long enough
she'll get better and better at it until
she'll get like really good at it and
then the time between the emergence of
the problem and the solution will just
it'll collapse to the point where it's
virtually immediate now that can take
that's a very high level of Mastery that
can take a very long time but then you
know you also want to put forward to
your wife and yourself the proposition
that you're better than you are which is
well I can okay I get the problem I can
solve it it's like no you probably don't
get the problem and even if you did it
isn't necessarily the case that you
could solve it and so you have to put up
with the fact that you're going to have
to be dragged through the mud uh cuz
she's going to point to you know maybe
her kids up set because you're a tyrant
and you probably are a tyrant to some
degree you know clomping around
overconfident and all that and so she's
going to poke you well maybe you're this
is how you're stupid and maybe this is
how you're stupid and maybe this is how
you're long list of potential ways and
actual ways you could be stupid so you
have to listen to that
now your wife has to act in good faith
you know one of the things that Tammy
and I did when we first got married
because I I thought a lot of this
through before we got married I said
look you know if we're going to do this
you you have to tell me the truth I
don't care what it is you I'll tell you
the truth but you have to tell me the
truth I don't care what the truth is but
it has to be true right and so that's
without that you get nowhere and you
can't trust your partner either and so
your partner has to be all in that's why
you have a marriage vow because the
marriage vow is basically this this is
The Vow no matter what you tell me I
won't run
away and that's a of a vow man
because when when someone unveils their
whole heart they unveil themselves all
the way down to hell it's not pleasant
it's awful and so they need to know that
you will not run away and that's a vow
because what do you know look the
person's always going to be thinking
always if you really knew who I was you
wouldn't love me you wouldn't be with me
and you know
hey fair enough because people are full
of snakes and if all those snakes were
revealed perhaps the logical thing to do
would run would be to run and so then
you might not you might say well why not
run it's like well you want to run from
everyone for the rest of your life you
want to forgo the advantages of a
permanent relationship and you're full
of snakes too so you're both making a
Bad
Bet and so you make the Bad Bet based
based on the idea that if you are
faithful and you are truthful that you
can resolve the issues and you can it's
a good deal resolving
issues much of what you've talked about
stems back to Childhood trauma and
things that happen in our our formative
years I often wonder those holes in the
bedroom floor you describe the early
traumas can we they're often in the
bedroom floor by the way yeah you bet
can we ever fill those or can we just
put planks of wood over oh no no no you
you can't put planks of wood over them
you have to fill them and what you do oh
and and you can do this you know let's
say you were bullied repeatedly when you
were a kid okay you're probably still
being bullied because if you
didn't being a bully victim is a stable
trait so the great analysis of bullies
that have been done Dan olis in Sweden
did this he was a great psychologist he
analyzed bullying behavior and Bully
victim Behavior so we defined bullying
very carefully you're a bully if you use
power dispropor iately so like if I'm 12
and I'm picking on someone my own size
I'm not a bully right cuz there's a the
risk to me is commensurate to the risk
to them that's just aggression that's
just competition and even if it's
violent it's not bullying a bully is
when I'm 12 and you're eight or when
there's two of us and one of you or when
I get you in a position where you're
completely vulnerable and can't defend
yourself disproportionate use of force
right bully victim is someone the
bullies will check out imagine a bully
comes into a room full of kids he'll
poke at all the kids and one of the kids
will manifest a disproportionate
emotional response well then it's like
he just zeros in on that and those are
often kids who are higher in neuroticism
or who are fragile for other reasons and
then that can become permanent and both
the bullies and the bully victims have a
negative long-term developmental
trajectory the bullies tend to become
criminal and alienated on that front
especially as they move into High School
and the bully victims tend to become
depressed anxious and dependent if you
have a partner who's been a bully victim
for example that's going to be brought
into your marriage and then one of the
things that's going to happen is every
time you try to have a dispute which is
to actually think and solve a problem
they're going to see you through the
bully template they're going to treat
you like you're a bully they're going to
accuse you of being a bully they're
going to bring up all the times before
when you acted like a bully and then
you're going to have to defend yourself
and part of the reason that people can't
listen is cuz they also don't know how
to defend themselves it's like
especially if you're here's 15 pieces of
evidence that you're a bully it's like
can you counter those maybe what if
you're not very articulate you know it
might take you two weeks to think up how
to argue yourself out of that plus
you're going to be doubtful about it you
know so those are very complicated
things to work through but you can
listen if you listen the person will
dispense with some of their accusations
by themselves the accusations that can't
be dispensed with though now those are
questions you know maybe your kid's
upset when they he or she's interacting
with you and your wife says well you're
too hard on them it's like well are you
well it's time for you to go away for
like a week and meditate on that right
and that's that's soul searching right
you're going to go down to the bottom of
your heart it's like well are you a
bully are you a bully like your father
was a bully you know are you bully like
a friend who was a reprobate that you
admired and tried to copy was a bully
you know you have to see because maybe
you are maybe you should stop but then
you also have to figure out how you
would be if you weren't being a bully
then your wife can help you you know and
this is another good rule for couple
conflict like let's say I'm unhappy with
you say so I come and tell you that you
can ask me okay what do you
want if I could give you what you
wanted what would it be well I don't
know it's like no sorry I cannot hit a
Target you won't specify let's discuss
it at least we got to have a Target here
and so this is also if you're an
employee you got to know this if you're
an employee you're going to your boss
with a problem why don't you go with a
solution too you know and if you're the
sort of employee who goes to your boss
with a solution you'll racket yourself
up the hierarchy if you're in a halfways
decent business you will ratchet
yourself up the hierarchy so fast you
can't believe it cuz you'll get a
reputation as the person who can solve
the problem so and you know and you can
actually play with this and in in your
marriage because one of the things that
you can do for example is well let's say
you say something that irritated your
wife okay and then you can say okay
she'll say well that really bothered me
it's like okay it's an open question why
maybe she's too goddamn sensitive and
maybe you're too much of a son of a
it's like who knows right but you
can ask her okay if I had said what you
wanted me to say in that situation what
would have I said now that's a hard
question she has to think about that
it's like well what would what would
have worked and then she'll say you know
well maybe you could have said this and
then you can say okay let me say it now
then she has and but it's sort of like
let me say it it'll be sort of
fake it'll be a first pass
approximation you're putting words in my
mouth but let's assume that I'm trying
to do something better stupidly and
badly to begin with you know with an eye
to mastering it over 50 repetitions so
but I'll start by just saying it so
she'll tell you what to say and you can
say it now if you're absolutely 100%
unwilling to say it because you think it
violates your conscience that's a whole
different issue that means there's a
deeper discussion to be had but maybe
you could try it you know you could try
it out for size and maybe she could see
if that sort of satisfied her and now
you've got a rubric for for how that
interaction might go in the future let's
make it
concrete you come home at the end of a
workday okay there should be there's a
right way of doing that that you have to
negotiate with your wife you know maybe
she rushes to the door and meets you
with all the problems of the day okay
that's probably not a great strategy you
know because you're already up to here
you're tired so is she likely from
whatever she was doing maybe maybe she
was at work too you can't meet each
other when you're both tired every
single day for the rest of your life
with nothing but a ball of problems
partly because if you do that 50 times
you're going to view the person as just
a a bunch of snakes that are coming at
you that's not good even if the problems
that are being pointed to are real you
know you might think okay so you come
home after
work what would be the best way for that
to unfold and you have to negotiate that
and I would say we you know let's
parameterize that a bit you're probably
hungry well you don't want to talk to
someone this is another great rule don't
talk to your partner about something
complicated when they're hungry it's not
going to work so maybe you come home you
have something to eat you kick off your
shoes maybe you take 10 minutes for
yourself and then you can talk but you
you want to get that right or maybe you
come home you meet each other at the
door she gives you a hug you have
something to eat you relax for a minute
maybe you have a shower but then you've
already negotiated about when you're
going to have a conversation and you're
going to be prepared for it now people
do this in their business you don't just
randomly discuss a bunch of problems at
your business if it's running reasonably
well you have a meeting it's
parameterized you kind of have an agenda
you have to do that at home you have
your your home is also a small business
and it has to be run like that and you
have to spend 90 minutes at least 90
minutes a week with your wife just
running the damn business and I can tell
you if you don't do that you'll never
get to the play ever cuz maybe you you
know you'll be romantically interested
in each other and you you want to spend
some time together but there's a bunch
of problems brewing and your wife will
definitely do this will absolutely
happen is that when you're trying to be
interested in each other these things
will come into her mind and distract her
and she'll bring them up and then you'll
get pissed off because it's like well
we're supposed to be having fun at we're
supposed to be attending to each other
why are you bringing that up and the
answer
is well we're together and these are
problems we haven't set aside time to
deal with them the the reason you should
listen to your wife is because if you
listen to her enough she'll tell you
what's wrong and what she wants and then
you can fix what's wrong and you can
give her what she
wants in your practice have you ever
encountered those holes in the bedroom
those childhood traumas that you
realized at some point when you stared
into the patient's eyes they could never
solve
yes
yes yeah a bottomless
Abyss yeah it's
awful yeah I was in shsu ations where
you know I'd get to the bottom of it I
thought and
then it was like Dante's so Dante's
Inferno for everyone who is reading
listening you you should read that book
Dante's Inferno is a Topography of
hell so underneath every problem is
layers of problems right right to the
bottom for Dante the worst problem was
betrayal right and the reason betrayals
the worst problem is like if you and I
want to have a relationship we have have
trust each other and betrayal is the
violation of the trust upon which
relationships are predicated so it blows
apart everything it's the lowest level
of hell for Dante the bottom of hell was
filled with betrayers and that's right
that's childhood sexual abuse like it's
the ultimate betrayal right it's the
it's the a child sexual predator is
someone who takes the role of Guardian
to be the wolf right it's the worst form
of betrayal and so it just devastates
children and because they're actually
faced with the problem of malevolence at
a very early age and they what the it's
like you're four and now you see the
bottom of Hell well that's trauma and
the only the way you treat that by the
way is you walk people through a
Topography of hell that's what you do
and and you can do that well let's say
you were abused when you were a kid okay
so what's your problem well your problem
is you've seen Into the Heart of
Darkness that's your problem and just
blew you into into pieces could people
really be like that is that my
father right is that my uncle how could
he do that well that's you're gazing
into the face of malevolence itself you
have to develop a philosophy of Good and
Evil it's a religious philosophy
essentially because a philosophy of Good
and Evil is a religious philosophy those
are the same thing you have to you have
to develop a philosophy of evil and then
you have to understand how you combat
that and that's very complicated how do
you combat evil with truth with love
with beauty you have to start to embody
that you know or maybe it's even worse
you're traumatized because you did
something like brutal seriously brutal
and maybe you enjoyed it that's a very
common Pathway to post-traumatic stress
disorder for people and that
post-traumatic stress disorder occurs
when you have a very large hole that you
know gapes large enough to swallow virt
virtually everything that hasn't been
fixed or papered over you do that by
finding your way out of hell and that's
what happens in The Inferno too Dante is
guided through Hell by Virgil who's the
spirit that guides you through hell
that's a good way of thinking about it
so and every problem even the problems
your wife brings to you especially if
they repeat there are levels underneath
that and at the bottom there's a
betrayal something like that there's
some bit of Hell in there somewhere and
so and sometimes you know if you go all
the way to the bottom and you solve that
bottom problem you'll solve a whole
bunch of peripheral
problems so
in there's a movie Apocalypse Now that's
about a journey to the Heart of Darkness
and that's what the book is about con
Joseph Conrad's book and there's a
documentary called Heart of Darkness
that describes the making of Apocalypse
Now and the people who made Apocalypse
Now which was a movie about a journey to
the Heart of Darkness it had an effect
on them while they were making the movie
and all of the people that were acting
in the movie and directing and producing
and financing all went on a journey to
the Heart of Darkness inside and it
virtually killed them one of them had a
heart attack one of them went completely
broke like they just had a catastrophe
when they were making this movie they
fell into its archetypal clutches Heart
of Darkness is the name of the
documentary it's fascinating have you
been on that Journey yourself yeah yeah
yeah sort of I would say in some ways
permanently when I when back when I was
20 something like that 20 I started
studying atrocity right and so I was
I've always been interested in the
Holocaust osz in particular but it's a
very particular
interest like
evil Nazi
Germany
owitz prison guard prison guard who
enjoyed his work right because my my
question was how could you be an owitz
prison guard who enjoyed his work now
one answer is well you're just like a
demon from another planet who's so
unlike me that I don't even have to
worry about it and that's a very
convenient answer but it's not
true many many many many of the people
not all many of the people who were
involved in the Nazi atrocities were
perfectly Ordinary People they were just
like you and you think no I wouldn't do
that it's like that's not what the
evidence
suggests the evidence suggests that the
vast majority of people in Nazi Germany
went along with it now not all of them
were dragged into to the abyss itself
but plenty were and if you think you
wouldn't have been one of them that just
means it's highly likely that you would
have because you have no idea what
you're capable of there's a great book
about that it's terrifying book called
Ordinary men and it's about the
initiation of a police Battalion from
Germany who went to Poland after the
Germans marched into Poland now these
were ordinary men they were policemen
middle-aged who had grown up before the
Nazi propaganda mil got going okay so
they weren't indoctrinated Nazis from
like the time they were four they're
just ordinary middle class guys plus
their Commander told them in Poland when
they were starting to do military work
even though they were civilian policemen
that they could go home that they didn't
have to do this job and that there would
be no repercussions and in fact out of
the Battalion a number of men right at
the beginning said I'm not doing this
and they went home Mo the vast majority
went l
now why okay so now these policemen are
in Poland and they've been told a story
which is that you know Germany's at War
and the reason for that is that evil
Jews have conspired up a you know a
conspiracy and they've United the
Western World against us and they're a
fifth column within the country and your
patriotic duty is to root them out now
that we're in Poland and you're saving
the Fatherland and there's going to be
Dirty Work associated with it and do you
really want to leave all that to your
compatriots you know your companions
your your guys cuz like if you and I are
together and someone that we're working
for presents us with a dirty job and I
say well I'm not doing that well then I
leave it to you so there's a kind of
betrayal that's built into that now the
guys that left thought I don't care I'm
not doing this but most people didn't
and part of the reason they didn't do it
is because they were loyal to their to
their peers by the end of this which
took months these guys were taking n
naked pregnant women out into the middle
of fields and shooting them in the back
of the head
like and be becoming violently ill
because of doing so and tearing
themselves into shreds internally like
sick sick at
heart but doing it and that's a it's a
terrible thing to look at and I started
looking at that like it's 40 years ago
now you know was
shocking and so what did I discover well
I discovered a lot of things I
discovered that the ro road to
totalitarian hell and atrocity is paved
with lies like lies are the pathway to
Hell really like practically and
metaphysically and so one of the things
I decided this was in 1985 was that I
was not I was going to stop lying what
does that mean
practically lies ruin your
life there's so you will not accept a
white lie you won't C well look a white
lie is worse than better than a black
lie but
look if you're really telling the truth
you're serving Truth at every level of
analysis simultaneously it's right so if
if my words are landing properly they're
going to be the words that work right
now and tomorrow and a week from now and
a month from now and they're going to
work for me and they're going to work
for you so a true statement has levels
of application and a white lie is a
statement that's true at one level and
false at another now you might not be
able to maybe you don't have the
wherewithal at that moment to come up
with the statement that satisfies all
the truth conditions at every level and
so you default to the best you can
manage you know your wife says do I look
fat in this dress you know or or maybe
she says how do I look in this dress and
you think you don't like that dress and
you know the easy thing to do is to say
I love it dear whatever you want or you
know of course not but that's and that's
a white lie but that's not the optimal
answer like a better answer to that is
um don't ask me questions like
that and then you can have a discussion
about it see the thing is I've done I
bought a lot of clothes for my wife I
like clothes shopping for my wife and I
tell her how I think she looks and the
advantage to that is that if I tell her
that she looks good she knows I mean it
right I'm not muddying up the water and
if I have to say something I mean I it's
not like I the number of times that I've
told her that I'm not happy with the way
she's presenting it like it's it's
virtually that virtually never happens
she actually has extremely good taste
and so it's just an example but if
you're forced into a situation where you
have to tell a white lie there's snakes
somewhere that you haven't dealt with
and maybe the best you can do and that's
Leonard Cohen the poet said there's no
decent place to stand in a massacre you
may have already compromised yourself to
the point where in that situation the
best you can do is a lie but that means
that you shouldn't have Bloody well
being there to begin with and the
antidot in many respects is honesty
further Upstream honesty with yourself
and others further Upstream you can get
yourself in positions where all of your
options are bad and what that means is
exactly as you pointed out you did
something Upstream man now one of the
things you do in therapy is you find out
what people did Upstream you know and
you'll find this in your discussions
with your wife there'll be a problem and
as you Circle towards it you'll see
oh this is where I made a mistake
right this is what's wrong with me and
then you can even you can even find out
if you look you can you can go back into
your past and you can think oh yeah
that's when I made that decision I knew
when I made it it was bad decision you
know and your life is full of the
consequences of decisions you took in
the past that put you on the wrong
path and you said we were talking about
repairing things what you do is you go
back to where you made the mistake you
figure out what the mistake
was you know there's this cartoon Trope
that there's an angel on one shoulder
and a devil on the other well you come
to a crossroad that's also where you
meet the devil go this way or that way
if you go the wrong direction your life
will be then the consequences of that
bad choice and then that will tangle you
up and then you'll suffer for it then
you have to figure out okay what's the
suffering what's the problem when did I
make the bad choice which road should
have I taken that's how you fix a trauma
you you replace the road Road you did
take with the road you should have taken
and now you have a road forward and once
you have a road forward the trauma is no
longer traumatic because you have a road
your brain brings up the
past because you have not specified the
proper Road forward you go back into the
road you took that was the wrong road
you find out what the right Road was now
you've you've atoned you've
confessed you've repented and you have
specified the proper pathway forward and
that's what you do when you negotiate a
solution to a problem with your wife too
here's what we're do here's the problem
here's what we did wrong here's what
we'll try to do in the future and if
that new future Map works that past
trauma will be rendered
irrelevant as you know because I've been
sent thousands of messages these
conversation cards Salah exceptionally
quick so here's the deal I'm going to
make with you if you join the waiting
list which is in the description below
you will get sent access to buy these
conversation cards 1 hour before anybody
else they're in limited suppli so if you
really do want to get your hands on them
please do add your name to the waiting
list in the description below and you
can find that waiting list at the
conversation cards.com but I'll also
include it in the description below
wherever you're listening to this
episode how much do you really know
about your health for me that answer was
simple the answer was very little until
whoop came along as you guys know they
sponsor this podcast but even before
then whoop was integral for me to know
what's going on inside my body most of
my friends my family and my team now use
but I still have a few friends that
are on the fence about getting on board
and what I hear from some of those
friends is that they're a little bit
worried about what they might see in the
data and they might feel uncomfortable
about knowing what's going on inside
their body if I have learned anything it
is that knowledge is power and once I
finally started to look at the data and
understand how getting less sleep was
affecting my body and how my old
lifestyle was actually hurting my
long-term Health everything changed for
the better so if this is something that
you'd like to try out head over to join.
whoop.com
CEO and you'll get to try whoop for 30
days risk-free with zero commitment try
it and let me know how you get on I was
looking at our past conversation and I
thought it would be interesting to see
who the audience were that their
demographic and the the age group were
20 to 4 year olds really 18 to 40 year
olds my question to you is in their
lives in that demographics lives what do
you think the biggest challenge is
because your both your kids Julian and
Michaela both fit into that that
category as well what is the greatest
challenge that that demographic face
well the biggest challenges we had with
our kids was see I think the big biggest
challenge I had in my generation was
negotiating the years between 13 and 15
something like that that but my sense is
now the biggest challenge to young
people is negotiating the transition
into adulthood into adulthood identity
and I think that's partly why we
have this terrible war in our culture
about what constitutes identity and I
think the reason that identity has
become such a problem is that our
concepts of identity are unbelievably
unsophisticated narrow hedonistic and
self-serving so the identity groups that
have popped up are all you could say
whim based identity groups they're
sexual identity say or something
arbitrary like SE like SE sex or race or
ethnicity something arbitrary but the
sexual identity groups are particularly
interesting because the idea that that's
your identity is predicated on the
notion that there isn't anything more
vital to you than your than the
immediacy of your sexual behavior well
you're not a sex machine you're not a
short-term sex machine that's not what a
human being is so if you revert to that
all you're going to do is produce like
anxiety hopelessness and misery it's not
a good solution so then you might say
well what's the solution and the
solution is something called a
subsidiary solution it's like so what's
your identity well you should get your
act together and take care of yourself
so you have to integrate yourself you
have to integrate across anxiety and
hatred and pain and jealousy and fear
and hunger and lust and all the that
that plethora of spirits that wage war
within you it's a lot it's a lot you
have to bring that into a Unity okay and
one of the things n said the famous
German philosopher was that every Drive
attempts to philosophize in its spirit
so all those subsidi sub subordinate
spirits that war inside you will try to
dominate I'm only my anger I'm or rage
that's the protester type you know I'm
only my sexuality I'm only my my a my
appetite that's the consumer model but
all that has to be integrated and then
you might say well integrated into what
well integrated into a structure that
serves all of those Spirits
simultaneously and harmoniously across a
long time that's maturity okay but that
doesn't happen in
isolation so then the next there's
stages above that okay so the next thing
is maybe you've got your act together
enough so that someone can tolerate
being around you so that so there's
enough left over from you so you can
play with someone else so you establish
a relationship marriage let's say you
invite someone else to join forces with
you you produce a United Vision okay so
now there's you and there's you as
husband and it's the
joint interplay of those that's now your
identity okay and so now you have a role
and you have obligations and
responsibilities and opportunities you
know you say well I'm constrained by my
marriage you know there's all sorts of
things I can't do which really means I
can no longer in the most primitive way
it means I can no longer immediately
gratify my short-term whims although it
could also be more complex in that I
don't get to pursue the things that I
need to pursue which means you haven't
negotiated with your wife very well like
if your marriage is a prison you have
you're either very immature in what you
want or haven't negotiated properly if
you've done it well you've got your
individual Unity established and then
there's a Unity within the marriage
that's better and why would it be better
well you could learn to love someone and
that would be better because getting
outside yourself decreases your anxiety
so we know as psychologists one of the
things that was learned 20 years ago is
that there's no difference between
thinking about
yourself and what you want and being
miserable those are
self-consciousness and negative emotion
are so tightly tied together that
they're statistically indistinguishable
does that not raise the question about
the decline of religion absolutely well
that's the next level it's like okay so
there's you now you're a husband right
and so your identity is those two things
in lockstep but that's not enough now
maybe you're a father now you have kids
now you have a whole another level of
responsibility and opportunity to flesh
yourself out and support and love right
so now and then well you so you've got
your family to together that's not
enough you've got the community to serve
so you want to serve the community and
then Community scale you know maybe
you're good in your local business and
you have a local business organization
and you're good in that and then well
then there's the town level and the city
level and the state level and the
country level and then you know America
is one nation under God that's the
ultimate level of this hierarchy of
identity and that's what should be
served most fundamentally that's a
definition
okay God is that which should be served
most fundamentally it's a definition so
when you're thinking that b is better
than a what you're saying even if you
don't know it is that b is a step from a
on the road to God that's what you're
saying the the medieval definition a
medieval definition of God was something
like the sum of all that is good or the
essence of what is good and so if you
believe that there is a
good then lurking behind that is the
spirit of all that which all which all
of that which is good that's God by
definition now you can debate forever
about what that is but it is something
you live in relationship to like that's
in escap that's absolutely inescapable
and you might say well I don't believe
in God and then I would say well do you
believe in good and you'll say no I say'
well then you can't act because you act
towards a good or you're not
motivated I called Simon gunning who's
the CEO of campaign of living miserably
it's a big man's Heth charity here and I
said give me the updated stats he said
to me 19 to 35-year olds which is that
demographic that are listening to this
predominantly um are twice as likely to
report being in crisis than any other
group right and the there's a reason
it's a very straightforward reason it's
it's literally this the more you are
focused on
yourself the more miserable you are it's
it's as simple as that but that's
society now these days we I know well
and we're encour well and there are
terrible forces pushing Us in that
direction you know like I could
attribute this to the idiocies of a
degenerate Protestant liberalism driven
by post-modernism but you could also
just as easily point to consumerist
capitalism it's like it's all about you
it's all about what you want worse it's
all about what you want right now worse
it's all about what your basist
appetites want regardless of cost right
now well that that's the same as being
two years old it's there's nothing about
that that's and why do you think that's
you anyways it's like since when did
what you are become what the most
idiotic part of you who cares nothing
about anything else and any other people
wants right now why is that you how
about this though so this is where I'm
trying to make a distinction
is responsibility is a good thing but
with responsibility sometimes comes this
idea that it's about me my outcomes are
about me it's all about me my success
and failure are a consequence of me me
me me yeah well that right right
absolutely absolutely well that's why
the classical Christian philosophy has
always been that you cannot infer
someone's moral worth by the level of
accomplishment so the aristocrats would
have said the Roman AR Aristocrats would
have said well look at me like it's
pretty obvious speaking to a slave say
it's pretty obvious that I'm better than
you first of all I can slap you and
there's not a goddamn thing you can do
about it and you have to do what I tell
you to do and I've got all the money and
all the stuff and I can make all the
decisions and I have all the power
clearly that's evidence that I'm morally
Superior to you but didn't they believe
that a God had granted them that
superiority to some degree so didn't
they often believe in Fortune as the
sure sure of course they did that just
made it even better it's like it's a the
fact that I've got the power is a
reflection of the fact that the cosmic
order is clearly on my side and we
believe that less now because of the
decline of religion so we now think that
our outcomes are more determined by our
own actions yes but lurking underneath
that is is there's a hidden God lurking
underneath all that too it's just that
the God has become subjectivity it's
something like that when God talks to
Moses out of the depths of the burning
bush she says I am what I am and that's
what every degenerate Protestant liberal
says now I am what I am and they also
say and if you don't go along with it
the consequences for you are going to be
pretty damn dismal use my pronouns adopt
my identity play the game that the worst
part of me insists on or else and it is
a consequence I I said Protestant
liberalism for a reason like as we've
moved away from
God we've moved into a rad
subjectivity now the problem with that
is that a radical subjectivity
especially one of impulse is
unbelievably immature and
counterproductive it just doesn't work
any more than a room full of
two-year-olds Works what's the better
idea this subsidiary structure it's the
adoption of voluntary
responsibility May way more complex
identity it's like you know take on the
load pick take someone in your life make
a permanent relationship work it out
have some kids serve
your Society at all these different
levels strive upward what's up okay
here's the definition of
up a better
solution unites more situations and
people across broader spans of time is
this why this brings me to you're doing
Peterson's Academy which is an online
sort of Interactive Learning platform
you've designed which is kind of seems
like it's taking on this typical
University structure I've I was on there
I see people can sign up right now but
why are you doing Peterson's Academy
well um
curiosity
um I'm curious about virtually
everything I started putting my lectures
on YouTube because I was curious what'll
happen if I use this you know so
curiosity but then the more deliberative
answer is I'm in a very fortunate
position because I can meet pretty much
anyone I want to meet and the people I
want to meet are almost always
interesting thinkers let's say or people
who have done interesting things
repeatedly in their lives and so I can
find those people and some of them are
very charismatic and they have lots to
say and they I I'm providing them with a
platform to say those things and we can
do it at extremely high quality and very
very low cost and we can distribute that
to everyone and I am an educator I'm a
professor or at least I was I'm still a
professor
and I it's time for the for what we've
been doing in universities for all these
centuries to be made available on a mass
scale because it can be done very well
and it can be done and it's entertaining
to do and there's no reason not to do it
okay so that's all on the positive side
and then there's a sense of humor aspect
to it too because it became impossible
for me to work in a university and so I
thought fine I'll go build my own
university cuz I thought maybe there's
something arrogant about this when the
university came after me there was part
of me that thought you think I need you
it's like I don't think so I think you
need me and if you don't want me around
anymore we'll see who needs who now like
I said you know I was irritated and
peeved and maybe there's something
arrogant about that but let's
reconfigure it so here's one of the
experiences I've had bringing these
professors down to Miami this is
especially true with the professors from
Cambridge and Oxford like some of these
people man they are deadly you're lucky
to have a conversation with them they've
been thinking a long time they're super
smart they're wise they know their field
they're great communicators these are
Stellar people and their universities
treat them terribly no respect they let
their students walk all over them they
pay them abysmally they treat them as if
they're Pawns of the administration it's
sickening and so I invite them down to
my Miami and we we make them a good
Financial offer and we treat them like
people we're very pleased to have there
and that we hope they'll come back and
they have a really good time and they
deliver and we say look they say well
what what what function do you want this
course to serve you know because maybe
they're worried that there's a political
agenda or something like that and our
rule is we picked you for a reason you
know what we're doing you tell us how to
get the hell out of your way so that we
can enable you to teach the course
you've always dreamed of teaching we
will provide you with the audience
you've always wanted which will be
people because they have a live audience
and the live audience members we select
are selected because they want to come
and listen which is what you want for
students and so we want to have the
dream experience for the professor come
talk about what you love to people who
want to listen plus we'll provide you
with maybe enough financial security so
you don't have to be concerned about
your damn University anymore which is
also something I'm quite pleased about
now I don't know if we can deliver on
that but even the initial we give them
an advance like like with a book deal
and even the additional Advance
generally is a sizable sum it depends to
some degree on their following right
because we do some economic calibration
but I would love to be in a position
where I could take like the best
thousand lectures in the world bring
them on to Peterson Academy give them
Financial Independence because that
would be really amusing and then to
bring what they have to say to to
everyone for like for almost no cost you
first you've taken a first principal
approach to trying to build a new
University um bringing the best
professors together giving them the
freedom making sure they're not they're
not sensored in any way giving them the
audience and the remuneration and
appreciation they deserve when does this
University Peterson Academy launch early
2024 we already have 30 courses uh
recorded something like that I'll put
the link to the university in the
description below on on this episode but
also you can just search Peterson's
University online and it comes up the
first
thing we usually have a closing
tradition on this podcast where the last
guest leaves a question for the next
guest in the diary but um I wanted to
ask you my own question because it was
quite pivotal to our it was really
informative and the honesty you brought
with it in our last conversation really
changed my life in a number of ways how
I'll tell you after I ask you the
question okay okay the question
is
how are you doing good good you know I I
still have a lot of pain so that's
annoying but not anywhere near as much
as I did have when I was really sick so
like I almost always feel like I have a
relatively serious flu achy it's some
neurological problem and I have no idea
what it is and neither does anyone else
but but I'm not anxious at all and my
head is very clear and
I have such a ridiculously interesting
life
that the the the left over trouble is
basically irrelevant you know I wish it
would go away but whatever it's not that
big a problem so and I I mean I just
have an
absolutely miraculous realm of
opportunity in front of me it's crazy
every day I have is so interesting that
it's almost unbearable and I would tell
people who are listening you know you
might want that for yourself let's say
you might want to have that and I can
tell you you can one way to increase the
probability that things will unfold for
you properly is to is to not lie it's
just stop lying
period stop saying things you believe to
be untrue stop doing things you know to
be wrong just start with that you'll get
closer and closer to the truth and the
truth is the truth is the adventure of
life that's the advantage to the truth
you have the world on your side but
obviously because if you're lying about
things you're opposing reality who are
you who are you to oppose reality good
luck unbearable it's almost
unbearable your life is
so exciting and so full of opportunities
that it's almost
unbearable yeah yeah it's like an action
adventure movie all the time it's crazy
it's crazy you know wherever I go I can
talk to whoever I want essentially you
know I'm going from country to country
people stop me on the streets they're
happy to see me it's like I have friends
wherever I go really it's crazy and
people you know they feel they know me
because they've been watching hours
often and they do know me you know I
don't know them but they certainly
approach me on good terms you know and
so and I go I just was in nine different
countries and I have a team of people
who set up meetings for me like dinner
meetings and so on in these countries
and they're always people they're
well-placed people in the political
realm in the cultural realm they're
hyper interesting people and you know so
I meet 30 people like that every second
day in EV in different countries all
over the world and so and then I have
these podcasts and I can basically phone
anyone I want who I would like to talk
to and they'll talk to me and so you
know three times a week I get to sit
down with someone who's like a bloody
genius and for 90 minutes they'll tell
me a whole bunch of things I don't know
so that's superbly interesting and so
and you know my books are selling like
mad and I'm writing another one which
I'm really interested in and yeah it's
great it's ridiculously interesting and
you
can I truly believe that people have
that at hand they have you have that at
hand that's there for
you Jordan thank you my pleasure it's
always good to talk with you it's always
good to talk with you too and it's
you've given me a gift as you did last
time in so many ways so thank you so
much for making the decision cuz I know
you could be anywhere so if you to come
here that that that honor and that that
decision is not lost on me so means a
lot to me thank you so much for the work
that you do yeah well I'll tell you just
so you know too it's like there's a
reason I'm here you know I have a team
that because I do have a lot of requests
and when you have more requests than you
can possibly fulfill there's a certain
pain in that because there's the
requests are almost always of some
quality you know so we triage and we're
looking for people whose podcasts have
reach and who have been successful and
who will conduct a straightforward and
honest interview and that will you know
that are aiming up and that won't play
games and there's a reason I'm here and
the reason I'm here is because of the
work that you've done so right it's no
favor I'm glad to be here but I'm I'm
here because this is the right place to
be right now so congratulations on that
thank you so
much
a quick word on hu as you know they're a
sponsor of this podcast and I'm an
investor in the company it is finally
here three years of work from H to try
and make a bar a snack bar that is
nutritionally complete as of the
recording of this episode they finally
release these bars that are high in
protein 27 vitamins and minerals and
just 2 gram of sugar The Impossible has
been done and it tastes so godamn good
often these snack bars these like high
protein snack bars taste like you're
eating Play-Doh or cardboard or
something it's so hard to make one that
is nutritionally complete and that
tastes good and ladies and gentlemen
here we have it I'm going to put the
link in the description to get your bar
below try it out and tag me and let me
know exactly how you get on because it's
so nice to finally have a bar that is
nutritionally complete and that actually
doesn't taste like cardboard and that
tastes
delicious The Impossible has been
[Music]
accomplished
oh